[Musik]
ich wurde angegriffen und ein meter 10
tiefe er hat meinen armen geschnappt und
zog mich nach unten in eine spalte
[Musik]
selbst wenn das meer so schön ruhig ist
die eier sind immer da sie warten und
laut
daher ist wieder freund noch feind wir
leben auf dem land er lebt im wasser wir
jagen auf dem land eher jagd im wasser
wenn du einmal angefangen hast so surfen
kannst du nie wieder damit aufhören es
ist stärker als die angst vor haien
wenn man von einem hai angegriffen wird
spürt man keinen schmerz er biss mit den
arm ab
man fühlt sich wie beute man fühlt sich
nicht mehr wie ein mensch das hier war
das paradies und jetzt ist es die hölle
wegen der vielen hai angriffen